provide advice to the chief coroner
respecting medical legal social welfare
and other matters that may impact public
health and safety and the prevention of
deaths
this death review panel into illicit
drug toxicity deaths was called to
review the 6 6007 deaths that have
occurred between august 1 2017 and july
31st 2021
a death review panel held in 2017 had
previously reviewed
1854 deaths that occurred prior to that
date
british columbia has lost more than 9
000 lives since the beginning of 2016.
this public health emergency shows no
signs of abating and thousands more
lives are at risk
i am truly grateful for the efforts of
the experts who participated in this
panel
23 senior leaders shared their
experience their expertise and their
wisdom in formulating the advice
contained in this report
agencies represented included the office
of the provincial health officer the
first nations health authority vancouver
coastal health authority doctors of bc
the college of physicians and surgeons
the college of pharmacists the bc center
for disease control the bc center for
substance use the ministries of labor
education health and mental health and
addictions the canadian drug policy
coalition and many learned others with
first-hand knowledge and expertise of
the risks and challenges associated with
this public health crisis
i would also like to thank mr michael
elson director and chair of the coroner
service child death review unit and
specialized investigations unit who led
the panel and supported the drafting of
the report i'm profoundly grateful for
the time energy and dedication he gave
to supporting the careful thorough
review
of these deaths of members of our
communities
it is my sincere hope that the efforts
and considered advice of this panel will
support the province's support to this
public health emergency that has hurt so
many and caused so much sadness and
grief across our province and that we
will soon see positive change and
prevent future loss of life
and i like to turn it over to mr michael
ellison
thank you lisa
to begin with i'd like to acknowledge
with gratitude that the death review
panel was convened on the unseated
traditional territory of the coast
salish peoples
illicit drug toxicity is the leading
cause of unnatural death in the province
accounting for more deaths than suicides
homicides
motor vehicle incidents drownings and
fire related deaths combined
before i talk about numbers findings and
recommendations
i want to remind everyone
that we're talking about people
people who resided across british
columbia in communities large and small
people dealing with pain and trauma
people living in poverty or employed
supporting families
people young and old
healthy and unwell
people from diverse ethnic backgrounds
people just like everyone else
the continued toll of unintentional drug
toxicity deaths has created devastating
impacts
on families friends and communities of
the deceased
to provide some perspective since the
public health emergency was declared
more people have died than the
populations of revelstoke kitimat
merit
hope or cumberland
more people have died than would fit in
save foods memorial arena in victoria
so how did we get here today
in 2015 illicit drug toxicity deaths
increased considerably over the previous
year
and in 2016 that number almost doubled
and the provincial health officer
declared a public health emergency
the numbers continued to rapidly
increase and in 2017
the chief coroner convened a death
review panel which brought together
experts to look at the bc corner service
data to see if any lessons could be
learned that would reduce the number of
deaths
the 2017 panel identified a lot of
information about who was dying
where the deceased lived challenges they
faced in their lives and most of that
information is held consistent since
that panel and can be found in the bc
corner service monthly reports on
illicit drug toxicity deaths
the 2017 panel identified three areas to
reduce illicit drug toxicity deaths
first the need to provincially regulate
and appropriately oversee treatment and
recovery programs and facilities
to ensure that they provide
evidence-based
quality care and that the outcomes are
closely monitored and evaluated
two
the need to expand evidence-based
addiction care including opioid agonist
therapies and injectable opioid agonist
therapies as well as a full spectrum of
recovery supports
three expand drug use safety options
these recommendations are still
pertinent today
naloxone was made widely available at
this time and drug checking services
though limited were available in a
number of communities
there is much work still needed with
respect to regulating overseeing and
evaluating substance use treatment and
recovery services
two inquests were held into deaths where
people died as a result of toxic illicit
drugs and jury recommendations into
those deaths were consistent with the
2017 panel findings
the number of people dying as a result
of illicit toxic drugs continues to
increase and twice as many people are
now dying as when the public health
emergency was first declared in 2016.
the chief coroner convened a second
illicit drug toxicity death review panel
in december of 2021
which i chaired and i would like to
personally thank the panelists for their
participation commitment and insight
i will now identify the major findings
and recommendations on behalf of that
panel
deaths are increasing both in numbers
and in rates
the drug supply has become increasingly
toxic
more drug death toxicity deaths occur
among younger adults the average age is
42.
illicit drug toxicity deaths are ranked
second after cancers for potential years
of life lost
indigenous peoples are
disproportionately represented in drug
toxicity fatalities
individuals living in poverty and with
housing instability are more vulnerable
persons with mental health disorders or
poor mental health are
disproportionately represented
in addition to fentanyl other substances
were detected for most of the deaths
in more recent months there's been a
rapid increase in benzodiazepines
detected in deaths
due to illicit drug toxicity
benzodiazepines depress the central
nervous system
and can make the reversal of opioid
overdoses more complex
naloxone does not counter the effects of
stimulants or benzodiazepines
those who died frequently access medical
services prior to the fatal incident of
the drug related event
deaths are occurring throughout the
province
while the highest number of deaths occur
in large urban areas vancouver surrey
and victoria the death rate showed that
this issue spans beyond urban areas
and smoking is the most
common mode of illicit drug consumption
and that's up
almost 50 percent of of of those who
died
smoking was the mode of consumption
although a number of prudential
initiatives have been undertaken in an
attempt to address the drug toxicity
crisis these initiatives has not been
sufficient to stop the rising death toll
a new approach is required
one that includes a specific
focus on the toxic drug supply
the provincial response to the kovit 19
public health emergency has demonstrated
that urgent action
coordinated efforts and new ways to
approaching complex problems
are possible and impactful
the panel recognized that addressing
illicit drug toxicity deaths is a
complex problem
and that urgent response is required
commensurate with the magnitude of the
current crisis
the panel identified that immediate
action was needed in three specific
areas which i will elaborate on a moment
the first a safer drug supply
second
a coordinated goal-driven provincial
strategy
and third
an evidence-based comprehensive
continuum of treatment and support
services
the first recommendation is to ensure a
safer drug supply to those at risk of
dying from the toxic drug supply
since the public health emergency was
declared in 2016
more than 9 000 british columbians have
died because of an increasingly toxic
drug supply
it's estimated that more than a hundred
thousand people in british columbia
have an opioid use disorder
the first priority in addressing the
illicit drug crisis is keeping people
alive
one of the primary drivers of the
historically high numbers of deaths is
the growing toxicity and
unpredictability of the street supply of
drugs
providing a safer drug supply of
pharmaceutical alternatives is necessary
to reduce
the number of people
dying due to the toxicity of illicit
drugs
as the scale of current initiatives have
been unsuccessful in reducing the number
of deaths due to toxic illicit drugs
provincial emergency powers and further
legislative tools may be required to
ensure immediate action commensurate
with the magnitude of the crisis
the most urgent priority identified by
the panel is to make safer supply of
non-toxic drugs available to people who
are at risk of death due to dependence
on the illegal drug supply
a safer drug supply on its own will not
resolve this public health emergency but
is urgently needed to reduce the number
of people dying at unprecedented numbers
safer supply is a broad concept that
exists on a spectrum from a medicalized
model treating people with a substance
use disorder to a non-prescriber public
health model that provides a safer
supply of regulated drugs to people
as people use drugs for a variety of
reasons
a variety of approaches will be required
to provide a safer drug supply to those
who need it in the communities where
they live
a medicalized model on its own is not
sufficient to deliver safer supply to
all those in need
we will not prescribe our way out of
this crisis
a range of safer supply models will be
required to meet the different needs of
people at risk of dying as a result of
toxic drugs
those could include prescriber models
public health models and community-based
harm reduction models
the panel recognized the complexity of
federal provincial jurisdictional
challenges
including retired exemptions to section
56 of the controlled drugs and
substances act to support a safer drug
supply to british colombians
nonetheless
both levels of government have
demonstrated through the covit 19
emergency health response that is
possible in overcoming legislative
jurisdictional and resource barriers
quickly in order to prioritize
public health and well-being
the panel further recognized the
critical importance of increasing
meaningful engagement of a diverse range
of people with lived and living
substance use experience in all health
system planning
design and implementation to ensure the
safer drug supply and distribution
mechanisms meet their needs
recommendation two
to develop a 30-60-90 day illicit drug
toxicity action plan
with ongoing monitoring
the public health crisis is now in its
sixth year and continues to worsen
public health efforts to date have not
been successful in reducing the number
of people dying as a result of toxic
illicit drugs
the public health response to covet 19
has demonstrated a model of addressing a
public health emergency that is urgent
evidence-based responsive directive and
publicly transparent
the response to covet 19 has been able
to address health
economic and social needs beyond the
health care sector and adjust planning
and actions as the realities of covet 19
change
changes dictate
as with the need for a safer drug supply
there is an urgency required in
developing an action plan that
establishes a management and governance
framework
sets clear goals targets and deliverable
time frames for reducing the number of
illicit drug toxicity events and
fatalities
given that indigenous peoples are
disproportionately impacted by illicit
drug toxicity deaths there is a need to
recognize the ongoing impacts that
systemic racism and colonial policies
and systems have had on indigenous
peoples families and communities and the
legacy of intergenerational trauma
responses to this crisis need to
recognize and respect the resilience and
strengths of first nations communities
and culture the work of the first
nations health authority to address the
toxic drug supply the principles of
indigenous self-government
and the province's commitment to
reconciliation
any successful strategy will need to
include the voices and needs of those
utilizing the services
as part of an action plan the federal
minister of health is requested to
approve the province's october 2021
request for federal exemptions to
decriminalize personal possession of
illicit substances in british columbia
decriminalization is an important
strategy to support people using illicit
drugs to
access services and begin to reduce
stigma around drug use
decriminalization further supports a
shift from enforcement to a health
response to drug use
recommendation three
establish an evidence-based continuum of
care
recognizing the immediate urgency in
dealing with a safer supply in order to
keep people alive there is also a need
for a comprehensive continuum of care
including evidence-based treatment to
support those with substance use
disorders
the previous panel in 2017 made a
recommendation with respect to an
accountable substance use system of care
identifying the need to provincially
regulate and appropriately oversee
treatment and recovery programs
and facilities to ensure that they
provide evidence-based quality care and
that outcomes are closely monitored and
evaluated
the approach to screening
for and treating substance use disorders
should follow the same evidence-based
approach that would be used in
developing monitoring and evaluating
treatment for any other chronic health
condition
there is still much work to be done to
establish a regulated evidence-based
continuum of care
as many individuals experience varying
degrees of severity of co-occurring
substance use and mental health
disorders there is a need to better
define and implement evidence-based care
and less stigmatizing approaches to
concurrent disorders care
similar to the earlier review many of
the persons who died as a result of
illicit drug toxicity had contact with
multiple agencies
for example health care service
providers
ambulance and emergency responders or
community agencies
people who use substances may have other
chronic health or mental health
conditions that bring them into contact
with physicians nurse practitioners
emergency room settings or clinics
these points of contact provide
opportunities for further engagement
screening support and or intervention
building an evidence-based continuum of
care requires an expansion of existing
harm reduction services
health promotion and prevention planning
substance use treatment with an increase
in the number of prescribers
psychosocial treatment interventions
recovery oriented care and an emphasis
on coordination and communication across
all systems and levels of care to ensure
that patients transition through the
system seamlessly with limited drop
the panel also heard that health care
providers do not feel supported in
providing services to people impacted by
substance use in addition to
establishing a practice standard
and training regarding assessing
screening diagnosing
patients for substance use disorders
investments in delivering care are also
required
in closing i would like to emphasize the
urgent need for action and recognize
that in addition to addressing the
illicit drug
supply there is a need for
evidence-based services to support and
treat people with substance use
disorders
the panel recognizes that the current
drug crisis is complex
but covid 19 has shown that addressing
the magnitude of a public health
emergency with actions commensurate with
the problem is possible
thank you
if you have any questions about the
report i would be happy to answer them
on behalf of the panel
thank you michael a reminder to media
joining us today to please press star
one to join the queue for questions
you'll be limited to one question and
one follow-up and our first question
today comes from moira whiten
hi good morning thank you so much for
kissing my question
um
uh mr edmonton and at the point i i have
a couple of questions regarding um
what has changed in this report from
the report you achieved in in 2018 and
can you speak to the
um
i guess how you perceive the province's
actions responding to the changing
elements of this crisis including
drug toxicity and
and the
nature of the methods and
kind of profiles i suppose with people
who are dying
thank you
i would say that that
in terms of
who's dying when they're dying how
they're dying those kinds of things
the corner service is reporting out on
that
consistently on a monthly basis and
since the last panel there hasn't been a
lot of change in those circumstance what
we have seen
is the um
the drug supply becoming more toxic
we've seen an increasing number of
deaths and we've also seen that um
though and the report acknowledges there
have been certainly a number of
of interventions um by the province that
those have not been sufficient
to reduce the number of those deaths
and
i think that
one of the the
major thrusts
of the panel's recommendations is
recognizing that
if
if what we're currently doing isn't
working we may need to be looking
differently and so if if we're confined
to a particular set of circumstances and
responses as we saw with covid19 um what
we sometimes need to do is change the
rules and some of those rules
may be around
who's involved
emergency
powers to access more funds but really i
think that the the um
the emphasis
in looking at six years in is on the
urgency of of actually responding in a
way and specifically uh to begin with
around a safer drug supply to reduce the
number of people dying
malaria do you have a follow-up
i do thank you
we saw a statement today from the
minister responsible
regarding the report saying that you
know
it reaffirms
the province's commitment to doing
saving lives
but you know
she didn't appear to address the um
you know the evidence you've laid out
here that the province's response isn't
sufficient
what optimism or do you have any
optimism to share that this report
will contribute to the province turning
around the crisis and if not
where can people who have lost loved
ones or drug users themselves look for
solutions
i think that the the the recommendations
um coming out of the the panel and and
with the sub actions under those um do
provide good guidance there there was um
uh
a really well-rounded uh group of of
experts providing that advice and um i i
think that um it will be important for
um
a response
to really
take seriously the sense of urgency and
and again
looking at
um
some of the the the modeling that was
done uh with covid19 is clearly a a
different kind of public health
emergency but really what's being looked
at is what were the resources brought to
bear how did we look at that problem
differently how did we pivot when things
changed and that's the kind of approach
that's that's recommended uh in this
report and uh i believe uh would make a
substantial difference in in reducing
the number of death duted toxic drug
toxicity
our next question today is from andrea
wu globe and mail
hey thanks for taking my question
um for mr eggleston the chief coroner
appointed members of the panel who
were mandated under the coroner's act to
share their personal knowledge and
expertise and that may not reflect
policies or official positions or
organizations
i note that there are panel members who
are representative of organizations that
have an important role to play in
implementing some of the very
recommendations contained in this report
so one example is we've heard from
physicians prescribing safer supplies
say that they've been audited by the
college of physicians and surgeons at bc
and they view this process
the scrutiny the stress the paperwork as
a deterrent to such prescribing
dr david unger deputy registrar of the
college is a member of this panel
forgive my confusion and this is only
one example but does he as a
representative of the college not have a
direct role to play in addressing some
of these obstacles
thank you for your question so
the chief coroner in in appointing
um
people to the panel is certainly looking
at
people who may have content expertise
have process expertise
and and
personal expertise around um some of
these issues and so in bringing together
the the people certainly those
conversations um are are
um involved in looking at
um
providing advice to the chief coroner in
terms of
getting input from from all parties and
that's what you see
reflected in this report
andrea do you have a follow-up
uh true
if
these recommendations are
not meaningfully implemented and another
200 people die this month another 200
people died next month who is
responsible
well i think that that we're probably
all responsible and i think that that's
um again uh one of the emphasis is that
there's an urgency
for for all of us for all of our
organizations
and and to really be thinking outside of
the box and recognizing that uh to date
though uh there may have been or has
been
much activity that activity has not been
sufficient um to reduce the number of
deaths and that's really where we need
to get to and we need to get there
quickly
our next question today comes from lisa
cordasco vancouver son
thank you very much i wanted to refer to
page six of your report where it says
that
on april the 11th the federal ministry
of minister of health will
give you that section 56 exemption i
just want to confirm whether that's a
hope
or that's a fact
and and if that is a fact what will that
mean in terms of accessing safe supply
is it a game changer
it's a recommendation all all of the
advice that's come out of this report
are recommendations and the
recommendation around decriminalization
as i mentioned in my my remarks is
really important in that it
signifies uh four people who
are involved
or using
illicit toxic drugs
that
you're not going to be
facing criminal sanctions it certainly
reduces stigma and i think what it
really also does is signal
the importance of a shift that this is a
health issue
not an enforcement issue
decriminalization certainly also
provides um
greater safety
for people if they've had their
their drugs confiscated
that may
create um other safety concerns for them
trying to obtain um
more supply but i i think really the the
the big push with decriminalization
is it uh signals that this is is a is a
health issue and it supports
people
coming out and and getting the um
the services and supports that they need
lisa do you have a
follow-up yes thank you the reason i ask
or i focus on that is because
you know report after report by the
coroner um talks about the toxicity and
that is
obviously the number one cause of death
and every time in response our minister
of mental health and addiction points to
the federal government as somehow
blocking that path to better access to
safe supply um
is that true and and are we stuck here
until we get federal government action
as as i had had mentioned in some of my
comments this certain panel certainly
recognizes there are some um
jurisdictional
issues about what province has
responsibility for and what the federal
government has responsibility for
and again i point back to the response
to covid19 about how
those
legislative and jurisdictional
responses and responsibilities
were
quite quickly and appear to be
easily put aside in order to address um
you know another serious uh public
safety issue so
um i i i come back to
um
the notion that that
came through loud and clear in the panel
is a different way of doing business
about thinking this is is needed and
part of that
certainly will involve
federal government involvement
our next question today is from keir
junos city news
hi good day uh how would the report's
recommendation of an expanded safer drug
supply how would how would uh that
differ from the current prescribed safe
supply model now given that many have
criticized the current model is too
difficult to access
thank you for that question so
um
again as i noted we can look at safer
supply on a continuum and
to date
uh that's primarily been through um
a treatment prescriber model
and um what we are suggesting is
we are not going to simply prescribe our
way out of this this crisis that we need
to be expanding the models of of safer
supply to look at
some public health models and
community uh harm reduction models there
are other ways of of
actually um uh doing that and again um
i come back to that's probably going to
really require thinking about things
differently and um that that may
mean needing to um
enact other emergency powers look at
legislative changes but it really
the requirement of
of of looking at this holistically
and more broadly if we think about
a picture of
of an envelope or a box that we're
working in it may be that we need to
knock the sides of that box down and
increase our options
here do you have a follow-up
i do yes with that continuum would that
continue ever consider
uh being able to offer safe supply to
those without substance use disorders or
opioid use disorders
is that a
possibility
i think when when we were looking at the
issue of of um safer supply we certainly
um acknowledged that not
everybody
who died
had a substance use disorder and the
importance of
ensuring the safety and well-being of
british columbians
our next question today comes from chad
pawson
cbc yeah thank you sorry just two things
the one is you said the average age uh
of the death is 42
do you have like a time of kind of like
a timeline of what it was before
unfortunately i don't have that uh
directly at my fingertips uh certainly
could follow up with ryan i could get
you that information
chad you have a follow-up
yes my follow-up is for lisa
lisa what what are you doing to demand
from provincial and federal ministries
that safe supply be established and
personal possession be decriminalized
thanks for your question chad so the
corner service
isn't in a position to demand uh we use
the tools that we have and those are
death review panels we've now held two
death review panels into the drug
toxicity desk where we bring together
people
with expertise and influence
an earlier question referenced the
college of physicians and surgeons it is
our hope in inviting senior leaders to
the death review panels that they have
the influence to support change within
their agencies and ministries uh when
the when the recommendations are
received um and we've held in quests as
michael noted we've held two inquests
into drug toxicity deaths and juries
have made very similar recommendations
so um our role is to investigate the
deaths present the facts and where
possible make recommendations to prevent
similar deaths and we we have been doing
that we release our data every month in
the hopes that it will support
meaningful evidence-based change and now
of course with this death review panel
with some really thoughtful
recommendations aimed at turning this
crisis around
it is my sincere hope that those in
positions to
influence change at a very senior level
will acknowledge that
that some some very courageous change is
needed
we've seen that doing things
the way they've always been done has has
not been successful has got us to where
we are today
and we've also seen that there is you
know there are changes made but as
michael mentioned um sometimes those
changes are being made in a box that
just isn't a good fit and maybe it's
time to as michael suggested take down
the sides of that box and think about
this differently and that would include
for example
different opportunities for the
provision of safer supply if we're
serious about saving lives then we have
to think differently about this and and
we have to meet people where they are
and i also recognize again and again in
the report the reference to including
people with lived and living experience
in the decision making having them at
the tables
because they have
they have the knowledge
and ensuring that that they're part of
helping to to assess the best way
forward
our next question today is from ahmad
agahi global news
thank you so much and i just want to go
back and try to understand a little bit
more for people where the disconnect may
be so if advice from
23 senior leaders in this field
contained in this report to implement
some meaningful safe supply program does
not come to fruition
you know dare i say this quarter or this
year
then
what will
i think that's a fair question
and i again i can reiterate as a coroner
service we will continue to publish the
facts
uh this panel has recommended um
some
approaches that are
uh a little bit broader than what's
currently in place uh at the end of the
day
it's up to the people of the province to
ask their elected officials to to make
the changes that they think are
important
and and i would expect that i i
certainly know from the many families i
hear
from
communities across the province that
this is a burning issue for them
and um i would expect that i i suspect
that many of those in elected positions
are hearing from those same families and
i i hope that we will see this
meaningful change i don't think anybody
wants to see
another 2 200 lives lost next year
because we are losing valuable members
of our communities as we all know
and uh it's
you know the life expectancy of this
province is decreased as a result of
illicit drug toxicity that's pretty
significant fact and uh i i do believe
that there is a real
desire to change this around um
and i hope that the panel's
recommendations will support that
meaningful change
matt do you have a follow-up
yes thank you so much lisa and it kind
of leads to the next question i i wanted
to ask
do you think there needs to be a better
way to communicate to those people in
the province who have not been
personally affected by the crisis
about its urgency
and what clearly appears to be
the impact now with so many deaths on
the overall well-being of the province
because if perhaps it hasn't impacted
someone
now um the way
things are moving it certainly looks
like it could in the future and is there
any way to get through to those people
better i know the reports have helped
over the last few years big time
but can more be done on a provincial
level with messaging
like we saw with covid how everyone got
the importance of that through messaging
from the province on a big scale
well i certainly think that um awareness
of this
public health emergency is growing
we know it is a fact that covid19 really
occupied
much of the time of many of those in
positions of authority in our province
and for good good reason um and sadly i
think one of the unintended complex uh
consequences of that preoccupation was
that um
the social isolation and the lack of
opportunities for
overdose prevention sites
had a really negative impact on those
using substances and we and we have seen
deaths rise to an historic level which
has been tremendously tremendously sad
for so many families
and there are the other either i have
seen an advertising campaign by the
province certainly around stopping the
stigma um encouraging people to call if
they have a substance use problem and i
think certainly the panel's
recommendations around
an evidence-based system of care
supporting clinicians and
healthcare those in the healthcare world
to assess and advise people experiencing
problematic substance use or even casual
substance use um helping people
understand the risks and helping people
know the solutions but then having
having solutions there and i think
that's been one of the big challenges
that we've seen in this crisis where
people are aware of the risks and people
are looking for help and they have not
been able to access it
particularly in smaller and more remote
communities and we have seen the rate of
death
rise alarmingly so
100 there needs to be more awareness
that of the risks um the panel has
certainly
provided a real sense of urgency in
helping people understand what needs to
happen quickly
and um
um and and maybe supporting you know
michael mentioned that those prescribing
in this world currently i'm working are
not feeling supported so how do we
support clinicians to
uh to help those who are experiencing
problematic substance use
there's all sorts of different avenues
that that can be explored
and again i'm just very hopeful that the
the wise advice of these 23 people will
help with that
our next question today is from camille
baines canadian press
hi and thanks for taking the questions
uh i'm wondering a lot of what we've
heard today regarding safer supply the
continuum of care and also
comparisons with how we've responded to
covid
these have all come up before how do you
think having the targeted dates in this
report could possibly help and how would
you be following up on that
well thank you for your question and i'm
going to turn that question over to
michael as chair of the panel because he
can better uh i believe he's in a better
position to explain
where the panel thought that these
recommendations would be able to make a
difference so michael i'm going to ask
you to come up please
thanks lisa just um just just before i
get to that i'd i'd like to make a quick
comment on the the previous question
about um
creating a greater awareness uh part of
one of the recommendations um
identifies
the the importance of actually getting
transparent information out and
certainly we've seen
the model of of disseminating
information about covid19 on dashboards
about metrics
and and
something similar to that
or along those lines is um
would really uh be helpful and that's
that's part of
one of the recommendations
in terms of
um
[Music]
if if i understand the question
correctly and if i don't plea please
repeat it but
that that similar kinds of calls have
been made before why why would we think
um that um
uh
this uh would have an impact
i think that that
there have there clearly have been lots
of calls from lots of people around lots
of things
in trying to focus
i guess two things of really trying to
highlight
uh this sense of urgency and also trying
to highlight a sense of
really needing to be thinking out of the
box and expanding
um what can be done
if if we look at
as a for instance the flooding that we
had earlier
how quickly emergency powers
came in
to to communities and roads that that
were completely devastated um
and and began the important work
of restoration that that was needed and
again looking at this emergency it's not
the same as as as as the flooding it's
not the same as covid
but there's there's a sense
um
that
if we use some of those same uh levers
emergency powers
looking at the resources necessary
commensurate
with the crisis
i do believe that
this could really make a difference
camille do you have a follow-up
i do we've also previously heard about
the issues around prescribers
do you have any targeted dates
on how colleges could respond and how
specifically
prescribers could be supported
well it's it's yes and it's not just
prescribers that that uh it's um is is
being discussed it's it's people in um
addictions medicine and and doing um
substance use care uh in general um
the the the recommendation i believe was
was looking at at two months to be
thinking about
um a framework about how we can can
re-look at how some of this regulation
works it's also thinking about that
as as i had mentioned
we're not likely to prescribe our way
out of this and that we need to to be
thinking more broadly um about uh
some other models such as some some
public health models and um community
harm reduction models so
we i think that's
was was a um
a sentiment that was
was noted quite strongly in the panel
that uh we really need to be thinking
more broadly um along a continuum
certainly including the importance of
prescribers but that it it needs to be
broader than that
next up today les lane times colonist
well thank you
mr eglinton you
reported four years ago a similar report
as today's and you had three big
recommendations about a dozen bullet
points on things that were needed to be
done based on the numbers you were
dealing with at the time
um
and you've obviously everyone's conceded
that uh nothing much is working and
what's been done to date
could you estimate what share of your
earlier recommendations were actually
executed by the government
and
if um
why did they not work were they just not
executed or were they just kind of the
wrong ideas
so i if if i looked at that and thank
you for that question if i looked at
that in terms of
an emergency response
and
ongoing support and care i think that
the energy
went into the emergency response and
it's it's i think easy for some of us to
forget that at that time um
naloxone wasn't available you know
without a prescription and if we look at
how widely available
that has been and it's certainly um has
prevented
a lot of of
um
overdose events
so i don't think that it's it's a matter
of of nothing was done the the notion of
drug checking was really a very novel
concept
and um though it certainly hasn't been
as widely
um uh implemented uh as would be helpful
it certainly gained some traction so i
think there
was
um some some um
some real action on on on part of
government around that emergency
response piece we've certainly learned
some things since then
but as i noted in in my comments
the recommendation around the need for a
regulated evidence-based
system of care
there is much work to be done on that
and um i i don't think anybody would um
would disagree that that recommendation
uh clearly uh was not fully implemented
and it's important to be thinking about
um these things um
combined that we need the emergency
response
as we have in in this report as well
around the importance of a safer supply
um but that's that in and of itself
isn't enough we also need to be looking
at um what are we doing uh to support
people to make services uh available
accessible when they need them that are
actually meeting their needs um and
again that that's complicated and it
gets even more complicated when you
start looking at um some of the uh
the needs of rural and remote
communities and and and issues about
accessibility
last you have a follow up
on safe supply or safer supply is it
your do you picture um
i'm just picturing someone buying a
street drug
and taking it in to be checked
and i i don't know what happens then if
if
are they told that um here's what's in
it fyi
and that or or are they told um
this this drug is probably going to kill
you uh we can't let you have it
what do you picture happening in that
regard right
so
um
again thank you for that question
in terms of um uh drug checking um
there's a a couple of things that
are are helpful
one is as you mentioned people being
able to bring um their drug
uh to have it analyzed so that they know
what it is they're taking because the
illicit
drug supply uh likely isn't gonna go
away uh tomorrow either and
it's going to take some time
to get a
a robust
and meaningful
safer supply out so yes that certainly
is is one of the the important aspects
of drug checking is that people would be
able to go in and know uh what what is
in their drugs it's it's not about um
confiscating um
the the drug
another um
um value of drug checking is it it also
allows some provincial surveillance and
community surveillance about
if if the drug supply illicit drug
supply is changing and if there are
things that would require
perhaps a community warning or just
knowing um
what it is that that's that's in the
drug supply
our next question today is from shannon
waters bc today
hi i also wanted to ask about the
recommendation um one of the
recommendations from the previous report
specifically the one
around a need to provide
provincially regulated and appropriately
overseen treatment and recovery programs
the province has made significant
investments in increasing treatment and
recovery options over the years and i'm
wondering if you feel that that
recommendation has been implemented
adequately and if not what continuing to
pour money into that system means
um
it
it doesn't appear that it it appears
that um money has been poured um into um
various aspects of um
treatment in recovery but that's not the
same thing as is actually having a
regulated
system where it's evidence-based and
outcomes are monitored i mean what we
should be seeing is
that as we would with any other
chronic disease is is that we would
continually be learning and we would be
evaluating our our treatment outcomes
and um reporting out on those and and
understanding what's working well and
and what's not and as as a note in this
report and in my opening remarks um that
recommendation
from 2017
still appears to need
a lot of attention
shannon do you have a follow-up
i do um so we've had this year's budget
delivered already and there's no new
money that's being dedicated to
virtually any of the programs that the
province offers in terms of responding
to this crisis i'm curious without any
additional funding being dedicated to
realize the recommendations made in this
report
what do you think the chances are of
you know the province's response
improving and
bc not seeing the thousands of people
die due to the toxic drug supply that we
saw last year
and and as as the report notes it's it's
it's essential
um to uh
bring solutions commensurate with the
crisis and and there is is
mentioned throughout the report about uh
the importance of if if what's currently
available uh isn't sufficient to be
thinking about um uh emergency powers
and accessing
um other resources that that are
required um clearly it is a um a large
task in front of us and it certainly
will require
resourcing again commensurate with the
crisis that we're in
our next question today is from dustin
godfrey burnaby beacon
uh hi this was for lisa lapoint uh you
set up the onset of this press
conference that you sincerely hope to
see change resulting from this
based on how the government has
responded to your recommendations very
like your you know the things that you
said in the past
uh how confident are you that they will
and at what point do you kind of stop
being hopeful and sort of go beyond your
role as a coroner and like
i don't know more
publicly appeal on a more personal level
to the officials who are
personally responsible for this
so
i do meet uh regularly with
senior leaders at the ministry of mental
health and addictions um i i certainly
have spoken on many occasions to the
minister
and i
i i believe that the will is there
there's certainly the desire to
achieve the goals that we as a coroner's
service have which is to reduce deaths
um there's there's no doubt about it
that um seeing these numbers of people
dying month after month year after year
is heartbreaking for everybody
and as a corner service
as a chief coroner
i do have the authority to bring a panel
so i i can work within the authorities
that i have and um we invited some very
uh thoughtful experienced senior leaders
to that panel and they provided some
very thoughtful uh advice and it is my
sincere hope that those in a position of
authority and and the many of the
recommendations are are recognized that
this is a complex problem so in addition
to going to the ministry of mental
health and addictions they're going to
the ministry of health they're going to
the ceos of the health authorities
they're going to the first nations
health authority and recognizing that
it's going to need everybody at the
table
treating this uh as as the crisis that
certainly i see it as as chief coroner
and certainly the families that we we as
a corner service are are
speaking with every month um
seeing it as a severe crisis across our
province and really hopeful that
bringing those minds together with the
urgency that the panel has recommended
so there's some really aggressive
timelines 30 60 90 days
and looking for
what is the plan you know what is the
plan and i don't think anybody
expects that there's going to be a fully
fledged plan within 30 days
but starting to develop the framework
for what does that look like in
combination health authorities ministry
of health ministry of mental health and
addictions
first nations health authority that this
is a very very much a provincial problem
very much a provincial challenge and
it's going to need a provincial solution
and
as as chief coroner i've certainly
spoken to many many people i've spoken
to all of those on the panel many many
times and uh there there is a desire to
change and i i really
appreciate the panels outside the box
approach
that if
what what is being attempted inside the
box is not working then it's time to
change the box and um and utilize some
of the extraordinary powers that are
available because if we really do want
to ensure that we don't lose another
2200 members of our community in 2022
then
then there needs to be some really
courageous different approaches taken
and uh
and i do believe that if those are taken
as michael said that we will see
meaningful change
dustin do you have a follow-up
uh yeah this one's from michael eagleton
uh you said that to an earlier question
that we are all responsible for the lack
of response from the from the uh
provincial government
but uh i don't know who does the buck
stop with is it the minister of health
the minister of mental health and
addiction the premier
and uh
i don't know what are your thoughts on
uh calls
in uh recent months for sheila malcolm
to resign
well when i when i said that that we're
all responsible i i think what i i
really am referring to is uh not just
government certainly government has a
big responsibility but um
uh
as as
citizens of the province
making our views known about how
important this is about supporting
families
who have
members who may be struggling with with
a substance use
disorder
certainly
the ministry of mental health and
addictions the ministry of of health
and and service providers also um have
have a responsibility i it's not
it's not a matter of
um
there's going to be
uh
one person who who is going to make
everything better i think that that's
that's why we need to be thinking
outside the box about who needs to be
involved and
and in that regard i suppose i actually
am hopeful in that we have seen and and
and i do take great hope from this we
have seen how
uh with covid19
um
looking at things in extraordinary ways
is is how quickly um uh
actions uh have been able to take on on
just
a scale that that i would argue was
probably unimaginable just a couple of
years ago
and our final question today comes from
mary brooke island social trend
hi uh thanks for taking uh these
questions today
so many times today you've mentioned
about doing things differently outside
the box
i'm wondering how much your panel
discussed the social social and economic
causes of the despair and the
disenfranchised
disenfranchisement that people
experience which leads them to wanting
to take an escape whether it's just on a
leisure use basis or they become
addicted
and
and with the depth that they may have
discussed which ministries are you
pointing that to
to deal with education about systemic
societal
change and specifically a lot of
exclusion that happens in society and
people feel left out and they kind of
tip over the edge
yeah thank you very much for that
question um
in in thinking outside the box clearly
when we talk about a um
an evidence-based
continuum
it absolutely needs needs to address a
number of things that you're talking
about um
the the uh the whole deprivation piece
so
that's really about bringing together
right from from
a health promotion
um
uh part of the continuum all the way up
to um
intensive treatment services and so
that's going to involve
education that's going to involve
housing it's certainly going to involve
mental health it's going to involve
community agencies
and as as lisa identified and really
couldn't
stress
um
any more supporters strongly enough is
the importance of um the people affected
themselves and their families about
what's going to work for them what do
they need but you're you're um
completely right that
simply providing um a uh
a safer drug supply is not going to
resolve this in and of itself that's
really a key component to to keeping
people um
alive
but
we really need that continuum of support
services uh to help uh people and and
it's it's not for as you point out it's
not simply going to be um
about the uh uh
physical um
um
addiction to to a particular drug
there's there's certainly going to be um
housing and
a number of other things for a number of
people who have some some some other
challenges and those all are going to
need to be addressed if if we're going
to make
meaningful inroads into the quality of
these people's lives
mary do you have a follow-up
yes thank you um so you mentioned today
about there are various points of
contact with physicians nurse
practitioners emergency rooms and
clinics
where engagement and screening could
happen
how much of that is happening now and
what do those practitioners in those
range of settings need
to
start digging into this problem
so
one of the recommendations is about a
practice standard around that and and
further training but
i i think
you've hopefully picked up from some of
my comments today that
those practitioners also
in terms of screening and referral are
going to need services
to to refer people to and those services
need to exist
on that continuum to meet the variety of
needs they need to be
evidence-based they need to be
accessible and they need to exist
that concludes today's event thank you
everybody for joining us today
you